so let's remind you then that the NATO
Secretary General confirmed in his news
conference the beginnings of a Russian
Advance do appear to be underway joining
us to analyze the latest movements on
the battlefield retired Air Vice
Marshall Sean Bell hi good to see you
Sean so this is happening then perhaps
earlier than usual seeing as it's not
really spring yet
yeah it's equipment looking forward to
the spring offensive well we're
predicting what's going to happen it's
not spring yet and there's been no
Russian announcement but actually over
the last two weeks there's been a
massive rump up in military activity in
the Russian side it's also worth
pointing out though that the front line
of this offensive is about 1200
kilometers and if you were to spread out
Russian soldiers in equally along that
there'd be about six meters between each
of them the width of this screen so the
point there is you've got to prioritize
and the Russians will have to prioritize
their efforts almost certainly the two
areas of priority are going to be around
the zapparich area around here and also
around this remaining area of the the
Dom uh the Don battle it is worth
pointing out that despite those priority
areas ukrainians are reporting that the
Russians have been bombing dozens of
cities on the Eastern side of Ukraine in
the last 24 hours what are the
objectives the Russian is going to be
well almost certainly they they want to
get some form of Battlefield success if
not only for their domestic audience at
home the challenge is they've got no
different weapons to use they have
managed to generate more uh soldiers but
those soldiers is very inexperienced and
and as a result the poor weather across
in the winter still going on they
haven't had the chance of training it's
almost certainly Russia's going to get
trapped into a very attritional form of
warfare what do we expect specifically
in zapparesia there
this apreacher I think it's more the
Russians will be paranoid about some
form of thrust by the Ukrainian South
down towards the coast as a result
offense is generally the best form of of
its best form of Defense but Russia
would have to open up a second front if
they were to offend go on the offensive
here not just in the donbass they
haven't been very successful with their
first effort up there so I think they're
very unlikely to do a second one down
here the ministry of defenses have been
reporting there have been Russians
digging in around basilifka here
anorikev uh just the north here almost
certainly preparing uh for the the
longer term and Russia has time on its
side here it's unlikely they'll predict
that Ukraine is going to do any sort of
offense until it has the Western tanks
and they'll take a few weeks to arrive
we've taught for quite a long time now
haven't we about backwards that will be
very familiar to viewers what's
happening there right now yeah very
familiar over months we've been talking
if Wagner group have been leading on a
lot of this so we've recently received
footage posted online by the Wagner
group that claimed some success uh Sky's
julicated this footage it is from a town
to the north of bathmuth and if we look
on the map uh itself it's all part of
Russian efforts to encircle back moot
the the footage was from krasnahora here
and as you can see the pincers are
gradually coming around the outside of
back move that'll force a fight or
flight decision for the ukrainians uh in
in bakmut itself
um they were they're almost certainly
planned to withdraw because they won't
want to lose everybody in there so it'll
be a plan withdrawal but they'll make
Russia pay a very high price for every
step forward they take and almost
certainly they'll be heading up to
chromatosk which is going to be the next
bahmut most military analysts predict
but they're digging in there and that's
going to be a lot more difficult not to
crack than back moon for me though the
part of this is It's really early for
the offensive to set off the weather is
still poor you can't really maneuver off
the roads the Russian Air Force can't
get involved because the air is is no
good either they haven't had the time to
prepare so why are they doing it almost
certainly a response to Russian police
physical pressure for two things they
want to see progress on the ground and
they want to see progress before the
Western weapons arrive in a matter of
weeks and it's coming up to the
anniversary as well isn't it all right
Sean thanks very much